Amber Heard settles her lawsuit with
Johnny Depp I pride myself on honesty
but makes it known just because she
settled she's still defending her truth
when it comes to allegations made by her
ex whose legal teams also sharing their
reaction
do you find that Mr Depp has proven all
the elements of defamation answer yes
six months after a Court ruled Amber did
defame Johnny the actress has now
brought the legal battle to an end
calling the move a very difficult
decision in a lengthy Instagram message
on Monday who was the real monster in
this relationship Miss heard quote it's
important for me to say that I never
chose this I defended my truth and in
doing so my life as I knew it was
destroyed in a statement to E.T Johnny's
attorneys reveal Amber's paying out one
million dollars a stark contrast from
the jury's verdict which awarded him 10
million dollars in both punitive and
compensatory damages no word from either
side on what led to the nine million
dollar drop today's verdict confirms
what we have said from the beginning
that the claims against Johnny Depp are
defamatory the actor's legal team says
we are pleased to formally close the
door on this painful chapter for Mr Depp
who made clear throughout this process
that his priority was about bringing the
truth to life I do not think it's
amusing but from Amber's POV it's quote
an opportunity to emancipate myself from
something I attempted to leave over six
years ago and despite the settlement
Amber clarifies I have made no admission
this is not an act of concession it's
time to turn the page and look to the
Future as for the payout Johnny's team
says he's pledging it all to charity
meanwhile Amber's also addressing her
original plan to appeal a choice she
made in June after the verdict was
announced quote even if my U.S appeal is
successful the best outcome would be a
retrial where a new jury would have to
consider the evidence again I simply
cannot go through that for a third time
I thought this is how I die across weeks
of testimony Amber and Johnny both
voiced allegations of domestic abuse
grabbed me by the hair swung me around
the tip of my finger
had been
severed and the media circus surrounding
the trial was Non-Stop
even becoming fodder on Saturday Night
Live Mr death are you finding this trial
amusing
a little yes so am I get back Captain
Jack
as for Amber well last month E.T learned
she wants to move on and prepare for her
next chapter in the wake of the trial a
source revealed she and one-year-old
daughter una page are living in Europe
where Amber feels there's more privacy
that she focuses on being a mom I'm
gonna move on with my life I have a baby
I want to move on Amber concludes her
statement writing I am also choosing the
freedom to dedicate my time to the work
that helped me heal after my divorce my
voice Remains the most valuable asset I
have
[Music]